hello everyone and welcome to the
mindscape podcast I'm your host Sean
Carroll and today is one of those
episodes that brings you a guest who
people have been hoping and expecting to
get on the podcast for a long time that
would be max tegmark cosmologists and
physicist professor at MIT
I've known max for a long time in
addition to being a physicist he's also
one of the cofounders of the
foundational questions Institute which
we talked a little bit about with its
other co-founder Anthony Geary a few
podcasts back and also a co-founder of
the future of life Institute as well as
a well-known author and public speaker
max sort of made his bones physics wise
by studying the large-scale structure of
the universe and the Cosmic Microwave
Background he's worked with some of the
largest and most important experimental
projects as an analyst as a theorist
taking the data from these projects and
asking what we can learn about the
universe but his interests are very
broad he's worked in the foundations of
quantum mechanics and most recently he's
been interested in artificial
intelligence
his most recent book is called life 3.0
being human in the age of artificial
intelligence and we will talk a little
bit about his most recent work in
creating artificial intelligence that
acts like a physicist but his previous
book was called our mathematical
universe and that put forward a theory
of a very very big multiverse bigger
multiverse than most cosmologists ever
think about one in which all
mathematical structures are somehow real
so that will be the focus of most of
today's conversation working up to from
our universe to the multiverse why you
would think that what it all means the
big cosmic questions that we'd like to
dig our teeth into
here at the mindscape podcast remember
for those of you who don't know there is
a webpage preposterous universe calm
slash podcast and there you can get show
notes for all the episodes including
complete transcripts you can also click
on a link to go to patreon and pledge
money when every podcast comes out the
people who pledge money on patreon get
episodes without any ads in them and
once a month they get to ask questions
that are answered in and asked me
anything episode so it's a worthwhile
way to spend your $1.00 per week on the
mindscape podcast and whether or not
your patreon supporter I'm always very
grateful for
all the nice comments all the reviews
all the ways in which people have told
me that they really enjoy the mindscape
podcast so let's go
[Music]
next egg mark welcome to mindscape
podcast thank you it's a pleasure to be
here now of the many things you're known
for the multiverse is certain certainly
one of them I just wrote a book on
quantum mechanics in many worlds so one
of the very first questions I get I'm
gonna give to you what is the multiverse
what is relationship to many worlds what
all these words really mean
so before we start talking about other
universes let's be clear on what we mean
by our universe we don't mean all of
space when we in astrophysics say our
universe we actually just mean the
spherical part of space from which light
has had time to reach us so far during
the 13.8 billion years since our Big
Bang units it's huge it has 10 to the
power 78 particles in it and huge
numbers of galaxies but certainly
infinite right and if you call that our
universe or observable universe and
space goes on for beyond that which is
what's the simplest theory of what
traded our Big Bang predicts the
inflation theory then there are other
universes just like it I call that level
one so but other universe and that sense
which means more of the same but further
away out of contact with exactly there
just could be other people living in
some galaxy a hundred billion light
years away when they look around they
don't see us because light from us
hasn't reached them and someone might
say oh that theory you have that earth
exists with Sean Carroll is just
philosophical yeah unprovable yeah but
it's all part of the same space this and
then if you take seriously this
inflation Theory the simplest versions
of them actually predicts that space
isn't just big and much bigger than we
can see but actually infinite and
moreover that the distribution of stuff
in space started out kind of randomly
from place to place which means that no
matter how unlikely it is that the
particles would have started out in such
a way that's Sean Carroll and Max
tegmark would come along 13.8 billion
years later and have this conversation
the probability isn't zero right since
it happened and that means if you roll
the dice again an infinite number of
time
they will it will happen again somewhere
else and you can even crudely estimate
how far you have to go until you get to
the nearest copy of this universe it's
about a googolplex meters where
Googleplex is one with a googol zeros in
a google is 1/100 zeros after it sounds
pretty crazy but actually much less
crazy than what you conclude if you take
this inflation theory seriously because
it actually says that there are parts of
this space most likely which aren't just
really far away so we can't get there
where the laws of physics you would
learn in school will be the same but the
law what would you learn in history
class would be different you know
because basically the particles started
out differently so things happen
differently but well you might actually
learn different things in physics class
- I call that level two multiverse and
the way you might get convinced to take
that seriously is if you both trust
people like Andrew Alan Alan Guth stand
under Linda who say that this inflation
thing happened and you also take
seriously the idea that the laws of
physics might have more than one
solution for what a uniform space can
look like we know that's the case for
water it can be solid ice or liquid
water or steam as string theorists say
the space we live in might be like that
- except there might be more than three
ways maybe more than a googol ways it
could be but this is a pretty general
phenomenon in physics if you have some
complicated equations they can have
multiple solutions and an inflation is
such a violent process that it doesn't
just create a lot of space but it's
really sort of jostles things around so
violently that it's quite possible that
it created not just lots of one solution
for how space to me but huge amounts of
many different solutions and we might be
tricked into thinking that the solution
that we live in is the only kind because
it's all we ever see but that would be
just as dumb a conclusion as if some
fish
in the Caribbean concludes that all
water is in liquid form because it's all
it's seen if it's swam up to Greenland
they would see icebergs realize that hey
there's more so that's level two
multiverse it's more diverse actually
maybe let me dwell on something about
the level 1 multiverse cuz I think it
does get glossed over a little bit level
1 multiverse let's just imagine spaces
infinite right the universe is open and
this is something that cosmologists have
contemplated ever since we've been doing
the expanding universe right and just
from that one idea it more or less
follows that there's an infinite copy of
people like you almost I would say it's
you could still have an idea which
Newton and Einstein originally flirted
with it may be space went on forever
like even Euclid thought 2,000 years ago
but there was only stuff in a small
region of it and then the rest was just
this infinite void where nothing was
happening but inflation torpedoes that
idea because it says actually all of the
space is created with stuff in it and
it's also not just the same thing piled
over and over again but it starts out
kind of randomly in such a way that all
initial conditions yet realized
somewhere so I agree with you if you put
together these two ideas infinite space
and that you do all the possible initial
conditions for them then you're really
forced into this this conclusion that
everything gets realized which is quite
shocking when you first come to plate it
and it because long before we if you
travel into space we get to that other
conversation between Sean Carroll and
Max tegmark a googolplex meters away but
you get the other ones where you're
interviewing max shmegmer and Max
tegmark - golf-playing and all sorts of
other variations of our lives and some
people really don't like that and this
is a conversation that could have been
had in the 1920s right this is not like
modern SuperDuper crazy cosmology like
the idea that an open infinite universe
could have been taken more seriously
yeah and it was pretty violently
attacked even before that you know
anyone who listens to this if you go to
Rome go to campo dei Fiori and there's a
statue there of Giordano Bruno who was
burnt at the stake right there the year
1604 talking about in faith you
where with other solar systems and so on
uh for doing a bunch of things including
that video there's there's historians
what a nitpick about exactly the reasons
why sure his tongue was cut out he was
burned at the stake but that was
definitely one of them well I would
argue that there are no scientific
claims to the stage okay but good so
level one already has some weird
philosophical implications in this many
copies of me then level two is that
there's also many different versions of
the local laws of physics far away and
just add that I think it's important to
remember that the things that we were
taught to be laws of physics as
fundamental the more we study them we
realize that a lot of those are actually
not fundamental but there's more that
information is more like just part of of
your address sense like if you if you
have a t-shirt one day which has these
theory of everything on it hopefully you
Shawn will discover one day all right
would you expect to have a big eight on
there and if I ask you what's the eighth
for you like well eight that's the
number of planets in the solar system
yeah that would be pretty weird right
because you'll be like max there are
other throw there other solar systems
out there too with two planets five
planets so the eighth isn't telling us
anything fundamental about space is
telling us something about our address
in space so they don't think that the
average temperature of the air on earth
is a fundamental quantity of nature we
don't iron metal we don't but we did
think for a long time that the number
1836
was kind of fundamental that's how much
how many times heavier the proton is
than the electron mhm
fundamental and then a lot of our string
theory friends that was actually they
have like a Google different solutions
and then one of them its 1836 you can
probably come up with another one where
where that number is 2019 so maybe
that's also just part of our address in
fact there are so far 32 fewer numbers
that we've found dimensionless numbers
with decimals seem to describe
everything we in theory can try to
predict about our world
maybe they're all this part of our
address also yep all right good we need
a level three multiverse then clearly
yeah so this one comes not from studying
the very big what's out there in our
physical space but from studying very
small things elementary particles they
were all made out of where in 1950s this
Princeton grad student you Evert came up
with this incredibly radical suggestion
earlier people had already realized that
electrons for example no other subatomic
particles seemed to be schizophrenic and
the way in sense they can be in many
places at once and people had really
bent over backwards to try to explain
that away for example the Danish
physicist Niels Bohr said basically
there's certain questions you're not
allowed to ask you about nature as a
Swedish person and I am honorbound to
always make fun of the Danes and I think
I think Hamlet was on to something when
he said there's something rotten in the
state of Denmark but ever had said no no
that's BS what's actually going on is
sure these particles can be in several
places at once but that means that since
we are made of those particles we can
also be in several places at once and
then instead of just freaking out and
having a stiff drink he continued
thinking through what it would feel like
if it really were that way and he
realized that if I make a measurement of
a particle that's in two places at once
and in advance I've decided that if it's
here I'm gonna go for a drink and if
it's in the other place then I'm gonna
watch Netflix instead what that's gonna
feel like is the there gonna be two
different versions of Max now and one
has a drink one watches Netflix and
they're gonna be unaware of each other
and it's gonna feel to them that there
was just something random that happened
they discovered the particle was this
way or that way and then life went on
and we actually have known for many
years that things seemed to be kind of
random in quantum physics and he said
that is the explanation Everett said
randomness is just the way it feels
subjectively whenever you get cloned so
to speak and
people still argue fiercely about this
as you know I do know know yeah but I
think it's it's important to realize
that this weirdness is so fundamental it
has nothing to tell even with quantum
mechanics because if we just go across
the river here - and the MGH Hospital
and they have a cloning device purely
classically well you did they just
sedate you and then they make an actual
copy they put all these atoms together
in exactly the same pattern and then
you're told in advance that the next day
one of you is gonna wake up in room one
and one the other copies in the wake up
in room two the next morning both of the
sean's
wake up and they go out of the hospital
room and look at the number on the door
right what do you predict that you're
gonna experience which are you predict
that you're gonna experience a one or
two what would you say I would say it's
50/50 I have an argument for this but
it's gonna feel random to you though
right yes exactly and there's nothing
you can do to predict your subjective
future experience although the doctors
would claim there was nothing random
that actually happened all they did was
cloned you I think personally that
everybody was onto something here it's
quite likely that yet again our reality
is really bigger than we thought and
that there is nothing truly random
actually happening in nature and and the
things that seem random come from us
having been cloned in in this sense
ironically even if this probably sounds
even weirder than the level 1 and level
2 when you look at the kind of diversity
you get and this which I call the level
3 multiverse it's actually smaller or no
bigger than the other ones it's just you
get all the same power of the world sort
of all over again and it in a different
way you get a much faster in some sense
I mean it's happening all the time in
this room right the universe is just
branching off yes and in some way you're
also more connected to some of those
parallel branches because if you are
upset that you got a parking ticket you
might realize that there's another you
that actually was identical to you it
was up until maybe ten minutes ago and
and quite recently only branched out so
you can take
Sawa's maybe and make you feel better
really takes the pressure off to get
things right
I just make me feel any different but
for better or for worse but you know it
does I reflected a lot on this before my
first son was born and because there's
hoping things were gonna go well and I
started thinking I have to try to align
my emotions with my scientific views
because what does it even mean when I
say I'm hoping yeah if there are
parallel universes where things are
gonna go great and things where there
you know and then tragedy right so then
maybe I maybe I thought maybe what I'm
really hoping is I'm gonna be in the
parallel universe where things go well
with my this birth that's stupid all of
them yeah exactly there'll be a version
you know maybe I mean that I hope the
probability of I hope that in most
universes it's gonna go well but that
it's also BS because if you're really
smart that's just the number you can
check it from quantum mechanics what
fraction of the world's goes well so how
can I hope for something for some
fraction being large just like saying I
hope that pie is bigger than 3 or
something either it isn't this is just a
freewill question these were all be
questions in a deterministic Newtonian
universe right where you just don't know
what the future holds is there's still
the possibility of hope so I think in
the end I ended up kind of a you are its
it feels pretty cool to be in this
universe and sometimes it's useful to
have those heuristics like hope even if
you know you're kind of on thin ice when
you say things like the hope comes from
imperfect information yeah ok so that's
level 3 that's the Eveready in multiple
worlds of quantum mechanics and that's
separate from the level 2 cosmological
multiverse where things are different
and the typical speculative theoretical
physicist stops at 3 but you will not be
stopped you're gonna go on you're gonna
say that there's a level 4 that's right
so of course most people didn't even go
to level 1 Giordano Bruno got burned
not just on the job market but literally
that's become more normalized
since now that we can see so far with
our telescopes and since inflation is
caught on even level 2 has gotten a bit
more normalized and moved from the
ridicule to taken seriously in our baits
I'll be if controversial and even level
3 it's interesting to see how it's gone
from being first utterly ignored to
being violently attacked being actually
regularly voted as one of the top one of
the top interpretations if you talk to
people who study quantum foundations so
it's it's sort of respectably
controversial in the sense that people
argue about it at conferences rather
than just in bars yeah right
level 4 on the other hand sorry before
we get to know you very whole other
issue that I gotta get right so I
personally would put a greater
probability on level 3 really existing
than on level 2 I think that there's
better reason to believe in the Eveready
multiverse then there was the
cosmological multiverse and I may be
very roughly 95% for Everett and 50% for
the cosmological multiverse do you have
different credence is yourself with at
the risk of being boring I think you
would agree with you on this because
there are fewer assumptions behind the
every Aryan one really all you need is
to assume minimalism it's just the
Schrodinger equations and have them in
my office with no little footnote to the
ifs and buts and this is not valid when
someone observers which we're not going
to define for you it's just the equation
boom whereas to get the level two
multiverse you really need to assume
both inflation and some fundamental
strain theory that has multiple
solutions like string or loop quantum
gravity and neither of those two are
things that we are that we should be
anywhere near and you know 90% sure I'm
at this point okay good just checking
all right so that we can get on a little
for it yes at level four this is this is
a extremely unpopular kind of multiverse
which this is your chance to convince me
so very young people who subscribe who
take you seriously you have a hundred
thousand listeners already to be
convinced yeah so so the idea here is
that so the way I got into this was was
first of all by just being fascinated by
the effectiveness of mathematics in
describing the physical world so well
and many people in the physics community
especially theorists like you Sean will
say our universe is really accurately
described by mathematics approximated at
least or maybe it's even exactly
described but then you have to ask what
is the difference really between being
perfectly described by math and just
being math after all mathematicians they
also have a slang guaa Ginn mathematics
that they describe mathematical objects
like the cube like the sphere like some
khalaby our manifold whatnot and what
modern mathematicians have increased
mean done is try to strip out everything
but just this brute formalism where they
just describe different kinds of
mathematical objects you can make a type
of mathematical family tree which I had
fun doing in in my book through all
these different mathematical structures
here are the integers here are the real
numbers the complex numbers here is
quaternions here is this 3 plus 1
dimensional pseudo-riemannian manifold
you can go on put in things with all
sorts of weird names but they're they're
all fundamentally the same kind of thing
now things that should be described
purely abstractly with mathematical
symbols and no humans are the baggage
and if you look at math that way at math
space in that way that there's this very
disturbing question which is why would
and in Stephen Hawking's words Stephen
asked why would God breathe fire into
one of these equations and make a
universe for them to describe and not
others or like what breaks the symmetry
why is this particular one that's
supposed to describe our world different
from all the others so the map the level
for multiverse comes from this very
radical conjecture that actually there
is none of that metaphysics there is no
special fire-breathing needed or
whatever all these mathematical objects
exist in exactly the same sort of way
and we just happen to be living in one
of them
one of them it's complex enough that
parts of it should feel subjectively
where what they're going on what's going
on there and so studying physics well
just break it down to plain English what
it's really saying is that we live in a
mathematical structure a mathematical
object which is something which has only
mathematical properties and and here you
have to stop and say well that sounds
completely nutty right what do I mean
you see the Moose here we have a moose
on the table yeah today not a few moose
it what prop what do I mean this has
only mathematical properties look at
it's made of cloth it has colorful garb
it's squishy blue and moose like those
properties like this describe don't
sound very mathematical at all right but
when we look at it Shawn through our
physics eyes we see that it's actually a
blob of quarks and electrons and and
what properties does an electron
actually have it has the property minus
1 1/2 1 and so on and we physicists have
made up these nerdy names for these
properties like electric charge spin
lepton number but it's just we humans
who invented that language calling them
that they are really just numbers and
you know as well as I do that the only
difference between an electron and a top
quark is what numbers its properties are
we have not discovered any other
properties that they actually have so
that's the stuff in space all the
different particles in the standard
model you've written so much nice stuff
about in your books or all described by
just by sets of numbers what about the
space that they're in like what property
is this space have I think I actually
have your old nerdy non popular yes
space has for example the property 3
that's a number and we have a nerdy name
for that - we call it the dimensionality
of space it's the maximum number of
fingers I can put in space that are all
perpendicular
to each other but it's the name
dimensionality just the human language
thing the the property is three we also
discovered that it has some other
properties like curvature and topology
that Einstein was interested in but
those are all mathematical properties
too and it's far as we know today in
physics we have never discovered any
properties of either space or the stuff
in space yet that aren't actually non
mathematical and then it starts to feel
a little bit less insane that maybe we
are living in a mathematical object it's
not so different from if you were a
character living in a video game and you
started to analyze how your world worked
you would secretly be discovering this
the mathematical workings of the code
right yeah that's an intelligently
designed environment but yes it is yep I
mean I guess we can talk about
probability that we're living in
simulation also later but if that is in
fact the case that we're living in a
mathematical object then what about the
other mathematical objects that happen
to also be well-defined why should we
get our high voices and say they can't
exist because as much as ours can maybe
they're mostly stillborn because you're
not complicated enough or or what not
but you could say the same thing even
about those other less controversial
kinds of universe anyway so that's
that's the level for multiverse in a
nutshell it's them is simply the it's
math space space of all mathematical
objects that exist and if this is true
the first prediction it makes is that
all the properties of our universe even
the ones we haven't yet been able to
understand to do with intelligence and
consciousness for example should
ultimately also succumb to mathematical
description but just to be clear maybe
it sneaked under the radar there we can
imagine the space of all mathematical
structures but you're making the extra
statement that they're all equally real
and we just live in one of them it's
that fear that's right that's the level
for multi that's right I really want to
strip out as much human baggage as
possible from this and saying that
something is real or not
what does it even mean well it means
something if you have this sort of very
pagan kind of idea that this moose is
real because it's made of stuff that's
real right but then we come and look as
physicists again and this just made of
all these stuff is just these elementary
particles and what are their properties
they're all mathematical so you can what
is there here really beyond all these
mathematical properties I have yet to be
convinced I have a lot of usually when
people start trying to persuade me of
things beyond that it starts to feel
very much like some sort of new agey
saying that they won't they just want
there to be something fluffy and fuzzy
and non-mathematical because they don't
think mathematics is cool enough for or
they say things like oh I can't believe
it's just mathematics I object to that
there are Kotori use of the word just
sure yeah I would definitely go along
with that I do want to distinguish I
think many maybe phrase as a question
can we sensibly distinguish between the
idea that our universe is just a
mathematical structure and that all
mathematical structures are equally real
no matter what you might mean by the
word real but at least there's no
difference in the level of reality
between ours and others otherwise it's
not really mmm a multiverse you're right
there are two separate questions there
first of all does our universe have some
non mathematical properties or not we
don't know yet if you had gone back 400
years and had Galileo on your podcasts
then it would have seemed like duh of
course it has non mathematical
properties like here's the only stuff
that we could even predict at all with
physics was motion Keller you could
throw a hazelnut and a grape and he
could tell you that they're gonna move
and this parabola shape y equals x
squared but he couldn't tell you why the
grape was green and the hazelnut was
brown because that seemed
non-mathematical he couldn't predict why
the grape was soft and the islets was
hard does that seem non-mathematical it
was to do with the mysterious nature of
stuff right but then we got Maxwell's
equations which
understand light and colors and even
that part of reality scum to the
mathematical description and then we got
quantum mechanics which explains that
why the grape is soft and the hazelnut
is hard and we've gone from having a
situation where the whole world seemed
just mostly magical and the only thing
we could predict about it was motion
mathematically to a situation where we
can actually apply math almost
everything except maybe intelligence and
consciousness there the file holdouts
well I did have a podcast interview with
Philip Goff who is a pan psychist
and the name of his book was literally
Galileo's error because he says the
Galileo made an error in making things
too mathematical now we'll plug your
book the mathematical universe which
says the opposite so people can buy both
books to decide which one is more
persuasive I changed the title in the
last second from the mathematical
universe to our mathematical universe
because I thought saying that would be
very arrogant is like the solar system
it sort of implies that we're the only
one right it's true
where´s if we think seriously that there
could be other universes this is ours ok
but wait but we got distracted because
you were making sales pitch or something
I already agree with namely it our
universe is mathematical but what about
the others mmm yes reality level of you
how do you make this jump from saying
there is so there's one mathematical
structure which happens to be existing
also physically that's this one how do
how do you then get to the much stronger
conclusion that all the other
mathematically ones also have a physical
existence so the first part I call it
the mathematical universe hypothesis
which is that our external reality I'm
fair which I believe exists and continue
to exist even if we all died that it is
purely mathematical and I might call
that the external reality hypothesis
that exists and then I have an argument
for why it should be mathematical but
then there's a separate separate logical
step mm-hmm which you raised here how do
you get from that to the idea that
actually all the other ones also exist I
probably shouldn't bore you with getting
into that too much in this in this
podcast
but what I argue in the book is you
basically just have to add a whole you
can take you can take some mathematical
structure and just study it very
carefully what are all the properties
that it has right mm-hm and you can say
this here is this thing it's gonna be
self-aware it has information processing
like this and if you're really smart and
can figure out how AI works in
consciousness or whatever you could
figure out even how the parts some some
cells where parts of this will
subjectively experience themselves in
there and you might find one that looks
just like ours you might find some other
ones and then you come to this question
oh if you're gonna claim that that this
one here the corresponds to our universe
exists physically also yeah and some
other one doesn't again what do you
actually mean by that you're positing
that there is some additional property
that this has which has nothing to do
with a math which is whether it exists
physically or not somehow but there's
this is nowhere to be seen in the math
right it's a little bit like if somebody
you try to convince somebody that they
have a soul and they ask you okay
there's my soul away anything and you
know can I measure its existence with
these particle detectors and then you
say no and then they and then they ask
you well does the soul actually push my
particles around and make me act
differently somehow and you're like no
the cell has no effect at all on your
particles but it still exists right then
wouldn't you say that you're making
yourself a little bit vulnerable to
Occam's razor they could just say I'm
gonna take everything you say Shawn and
just shave off the sole part because it
doesn't have any additional explanatory
value I feel that that so that just as
someone might say that the soul there is
like a little fairy dust that's been
sprinkled on but that doesn't really add
any thing explanatory you could say the
same thing about this idea that there's
this extra magical property that a
mathematical structure has called
physical existence but it doesn't have
any effect on the mathematical relations
that hold within it at all and I can ask
you well does that say anything about
whether these two lines that are
parallel are gonna cross or not and you
does it have any effect on whether this
sub self-aware object here is gonna
experience x4 why you know no so it has
no effect on any other relations in
there that to me also is just as world
normal talk to me now because it sounds
like this philosophical BS really that
has no consequences on any other
mathematical relations and I would just
assume my guess is that we it is just
philosophical hogwash and we should just
accept the fact that regardless of
whether something is a computer
simulation or exists in some other way
you know all that matters about it is is
how the what the relations are within it
that's what determines how it feels like
to live in it so they're bad thing you
have it basically a mathematical
universe and hey if you this leads very
naturally into this question about
whether we're living in a computer
simulation also because if you and I
were arguing about whether we in a
simulation right now all right and I'm
like no there's no way because this
moose here it's real feels real right
it's physically real and if we work in a
computer simulation the moose would not
feel really how would you respond to my
argument yeah that's a dopey argument
right I'm claiming that my argument is
basically the same argument but the way
I experience the moose max the computer
game character here has only to do with
what the mathematical properties are of
this computer simulation has nothing to
do with the where there's being
simulated on a Mac or a Windows machine
or a UNIX machine it's just internal
mathematical properties of this
simulation that matter I would say it's
the same with the mathematical structure
all that matters are other relations in
it not whether some philosopher says
that it's sort of made of real stuff or
not so I certainly delete forget whether
I buy it or not that's irrelevant but I
understand the argument that it is
absolutely a simpler idea to imagine all
mathematical
structures exist then to imagine that we
can conceive of all mathematical
structures and we are one of them
there's a lot of information that goes
into pinpointing which one we are right
which you're happy to get rid of but
then I think and at the risk of getting
a little bit technical here it would
seem that you to make sense of this idea
you need some kind of way of comparing
the different kinds of universes the
different kinds of mathematical
structures there's so many that look
like this
so many that look like that and I would
also think that once you had that way of
comparing there's far more universes
that kind of look like ours and then
explode into chaos a second later right
then to keep up this very very specific
obeyence to the laws of physics so
doesn't your theory make a prediction
that we're all gonna cease to exist
within a nanosecond as if both one brain
would that's a very good question
I think the answer is no for reasons
I'll explain in a sec but first of all
I'm totally open to the possibility that
this idea is wrong and I'm very
interested in testing it in various ways
I think to me this idea is more of an
inspiration for a research program to
try to find more mathematical
regularities because we're never gonna
find any if you don't look for them
right if we say consciousness is
off-limits because it's not mathematical
we're not going to discover any
equations that might actually help
explain and say in terms of your
question about whether the most generic
thing we should expect is just random
weird stuff yeah you please I have a
suspicion that um just like in cosmology
when we study infinite spaces and so on
we stress out a lot about the so called
measure problem to what you know which
things exists or a more often or to a
greater extent than others that there is
something very similar to that unsolved
problem here and I think it has gonna
have a lot to do with with complexity in
some sense maybe very simple
mathematical structures are simple to
describe get more weight
if you were just randomly bored and
simulated different universes on your
future supercomputer the simpler ones
would get a lot more attention than the
more complicated ones because they could
be evaluated much faster right um
you sometimes wonder this is a very
quarter based idea if the reason why our
universe seems so remarkably simple when
you look at the fundamental laws mine
might have to do with that that
simplicity is very much favored and if
that's true then we shouldn't just
expect the past has been simple but we
should also expect at the future we
should be kind of simple because it's
much more complicated to write down to
define a simulation algorithm or or a
mathematical structure where suddenly a
pink giraffe appears randomly in and in
my office right then to just specify the
standard model that we have today where
that's probably not gonna happen I'm
worried that you're I mean I sure as far
as that goes yes if there were an
additional principle that would somehow
favor simplicity you might be able to
account for our universe it's simple
enough it's a little a little
complicated but simple enough you might
hope for that but I do worry that that's
another metaphysical principle that you
were just trying to avoid your moments
ago you've gone away from the pure
pristine beauty of everything
mathematical exist that's all there is
to it so first of all I try to be very
humble so I'm not saying I believe that
just my job as a scientist isn't the
belief stuff I'm happy to make bets
though one has credence is one's a good
day's yeah and and and second whether
you feel that something is frivolous and
full of extra assumptions or complicated
or not depends a lot on what you mean by
simple many people criticize any kind of
parallel universe as being wasteful
because they waste a lot of atoms like I
don't buy this idea that space is
infinite or bigger than we can see
because oh my gosh there's always extra
atoms a different perspective is that
simplicity is you should be measured by
how simple the mathematical equations
are it turns out it's much easier to
write down some
equations actually give us this really
big space and then to write inflation
that makes a really small space which is
exactly as big as we can see and then
magically stops yeah and it's the same
thing we've seen in quantum mechanics
where it turns out to be much easier to
have the Schrodinger equation that just
has all these parallel worlds and to add
in a bunch of extra stuff it supposed to
get rid of all the parallel worlds and I
feel in the same sense that the level
for multiverse is actually simpler we
were joking by the t-shirt earlier when
you write that on the theory of
everything right so if you did that
2,000 years ago oh boy would you have to
have a small font you have to say well
and I will live in a solar system as a
blah blah blah and then this is what the
garlic looks like this is what
watermelon and this copper and periodic
table well if you just fast forward a
little bit they could wouldn't have to
specify the whole periodic table they
could just write down this equation for
QCD look for quantum chromodynamics and
three numbers and from them you can
compute the principle the whole periodic
table and books full of numbers about
how atoms shine light and different
colors and stuff so more simplicity now
and and I think by going to the level
two multiverse you don't even have to
write down numbers like that proton
electron mass ratio of 1836 because that
doesn't have to go on the t-shirt but
not just god it's your address you find
out if you want to know where you're
living you go measure that now you know
what part of the level two multiverse
you and the level four multiverse
economize is even more because without
it you have to put on your t-shirt at
least the equations for string theory or
our loop quantum gravity or whatever the
correct quantum gravity theory is I have
to put that in the level four multiverse
you can just wear a black t-shirt
nothing on it because all of the
mathematical structures exists you can
try to catalogue with a future computer
program exist and that's kind of all
there's to it I mean I don't want to
dwell on this too much but it sounds a
lot to me like Bohr Hayes's library
right like Bohr hey said what if there's
this library that literally contains
books with every possible
sequence of symbols and somewhere in
that library are all the works of
Shakespeare in the Bible and for that
matter every book ever written in the
future right the problem is finding them
you know the problem is that the card
catalog is the same size at the library
most of those books are utter nonsense
yeah and there's another problem with it
there's really no structure in it there
is no sense in which simple books are
more important than complicated books so
the average generic book is just pure
garbage what's so different about
mathematical structures is it's actually
very hard to write down a system of
axioms and theorems rules they're even
consistent at all so the great
mathematician David Hilbert once said
that mathematical existence is simply
freedom from contradiction and it turns
out to be just really hard to do that so
there's you know some people like to say
that you know something exists if you
kick it and it kicks back yeah
mathematical structures are a lot like
that
if you if you the Plato for example was
really interested in regular 3d shapes I
need to discover that there are five of
them he call it they're called the
Platonic solids cube icosahedron etc
right and no matter how hard he tried he
couldn't just make up a sixth one there
just isn't one he could make up names
for them but couldn't make up more so in
that sense mathematics kind of kicks
back he discover they discovered the
dodecahedron made of 12 Pentagon's and
thought that was so cool that they
didn't tell anyone they thought I have
magic powers and you see it sometimes in
art museums in the corner some paintings
discovering that shape was a little bit
like when we discovered the planet
Neptune it's felt like he was out there
all along and now are we found it so
this the math space is much more
interesting than than Boris's library in
the sense that there's a lot of stuff
not sure but it's there's a little but
it's actually not the case of just
everything exists it's not like you know
some people sometimes way to size Social
Sciences for being very loose and loosey
goosey about things if you just take
some random mathematical structure and
just add one more axiom to it often like
pops the balloon and the whole thing
just collapses to nothing so would it be
you're leaning on simplicity quite a bit
I mean you've also alluded to the idea
that everything that we do see in our
physical universe is just running on
some computer somewhere and super
advanced civilization is that simpler or
more complicated I would actually bet
against the fact that we're living in a
simulation not because I think it's
impossible but because I think it's less
likely so Nick Bostrom boost room as we
call him in Swedish popularized this
so-called simulation argument and but he
basically said was we're building ever
better computers one day we'll be able
to have much more simulated minds than
real minds so therefore we should expect
ourselves to be a simulated mind I claim
that that argument is actually flawed
and last step and you can see it sort of
start falling apart already by just
taking it one step further suppose you
agree with it so we're simulated there
is some sort of basement universe with
actual physical stuff but we're not in
there we're in in one of their computer
simulations nothing prevents us from
making the same argument again in our
simulated world we're gonna have more
simulated computers and they're gonna do
doubly simulated minds in the allowed
number us so therefore we're doubly
simulated and now we can do it again
we're triply simulated now you're
simulated a trillion times they're
getting sinking feeling at this point
well I mean go ahead didn't finish the
argument is it justice we should be
infinitely simple simulated is that the
argument that's what the simulation
argument logically implies there are
basically infinitely simulated which
already feels a little bit fishy and I
think I had the flip side of that or you
uh-huh which is that according to that
logic the large majority of beings
should be in the lowest resolution
simulations right because they're just
the easiest to make
and they would win but empirically we
don't see I mean it's easy for us to
make simulations and so we could easily
have lower resolution than what we see
around us therefore there's some logical
flaw I like that too that was even an
interesting paper a while back where
they had tried to look for evidence that
were simulated like finding weird noise
and things I didn't find any by the way
and for readers out there yeah but I
think where the argument goes wrong is
very interesting what it's saying is you
should have his basement reality it has
some laws of physics in it where there's
real stuff and in that basement reality
if you can there make the argument that
most Minds in there are going to be
simulated sure now you are onto
something maybe but we don't know that
we're in the basement reality right if
we conclude in the end they were
simulated then we have immediately
violated that assumption and we have no
idea in that case what basement reality
were actually simulated in so the the
thing that would matter the only thing
that could make this argument work is if
you knew sure that you were in the
basement reality so you can make some
statements about what so actually
probable yeah but just to be you're
you're totally on board with the idea
that many maybe not everyone listening
is on board I'm on your side here life
in a simulation would be just as real in
life as life in the basement reality
right I mean you did you could simulate
things
there's no substrate dependence the the
people in the simulation could in
principle have all the hopes and dreams
and consciousness that you and I had I
want to be humble here I mean there are
many people who think that there is more
there's something mysterious about
intelligence I'm thinking and think that
um it can only exist in biological
organisms such as us that exist sort of
in the basement reality but I I'm not
very fond of that viewpoint that I call
it carbon chauvinism yeah the other you
can only be smart if you're made of
carbon atoms I I think it's in fact
exactly the opposite of carbon
chauvinism is giving us the whole AI a
revolution the opposite of carbon
chauvinism is the idea that intelligence
and consciousness are all about
information processing and it just
doesn't matter whether the information
is processed by carbon atoms in neurons
and brains or by silicon atoms in
today's technology or some other kind of
particles in in tomorrow's technology
and if you accept that that it's all
about information processing then of
course an entity in a really good
simulation with the right kind of
information processing is gonna feel the
way they've lived the same way they
would feel if that information
processing happened on some other
substrates right and and just like they
will have no idea of knowing whether
they're simulated on a Mac or a Windows
machine or a Linux machine
they will have no idea of the way to
tell whether they're actually simulated
at all or living in an actual physical
universe that has those laws and so
would you say so not to put words in
your mouth tell me if this is accurate
it's possible it's conceivable that we
are living in somebody else's simulation
there so if among people who buy that
there's their response that but I don't
care and there's a response that but I
think it's unlikely for the following
logical reason it sounds like you're
saying you think it's unlikely but you
would be interested in caring if you
thought that it was like Oh totally I
you said I think we might be I have not
seen a compelling argument for why we
are and I think there's a little bit of
evident experimental evidence against
since I rent it seems like the quality
of this one is a bit higher than it
would need to be although sometimes when
I pay attention to politics but that
aside if you still have a lingering
doubt that you are simulated I mean the
advice is pretty clear just live a
really interesting life so those running
the simulation don't get bored and shut
you down
we know it's interesting to them this is
well so let's flip it around you see as
far as I know I mean you the thing about
being in a simulation is they can always
hit a save point and shut down the
simulation and start you up years later
who knows how many times has happened in
our lifetime right indeed the clock in
our universe need not be the clock in
their universe
this is where it gets scary well but
let's turn it around if if the
simulation theory is true then there are
super beings in the basement reality who
have built a computer or simulating us
and then a intelligent design that could
despise so much is true that's right
exactly but then what about the other
way around what about us building
simulations with a eyes in them I know I
had Melanie Mitchell in the podcast
recently a bit of a skeptic about a eyes
ability to reach human levels of
intelligence at least near-term now I'm
not in principle but no but how close we
are
what is your feeling to how close we are
because this is kind of what you're
doing these days right you're giving
more AIS in cosmology yeah my my
research group here at MIT we've been
doing AI research for the last bunch of
years and so if you look at minority
papers that's they're published in the
eye journals and the eye conferences I
and by the way it's got more a response
to the state of cosmology or the state
of AI or the state of max the first two
actually I am ever since I was a
teenager been just really fascinated by
the biggest questions the bigger the
better and I remember thinking back then
that the biggest mysteries of all were
our universe out there and I universe in
there in your head right now so I spent
the first twenty five years my career on
the outer universe is super exciting and
in recent years I've just felt even more
intrigued by the the second part and I
realized that not only that this pace is
picking up so much that it's really fun
now but also that we physicists actually
have a lot to contribute that field in
ways we can we can come back to but to
get me back on track you asked a
question what is sorry what is your
statement what is your feeling about the
state of the progress what's more
interesting than what I think it is what
AI researchers have said across the
world in recent surveys which is that
most of them guests hey I will succeed
within a matter of decades to get AGI
which is an acronym for artificial
general intelligence which means AI that
can do all intellectual tasks at least
as well as us super intelligence
something way beyond that and turn our
weekend act is that actually gonna
happen there's of course a lot a lot of
people who dismiss it and say forget
about it it's not gonna happen ever
because it's impossible because
intelligence is something mysterious
somehow and all those people say it's
about information or barking up the
wrong tree maybe they're right I would
guess that they're wrong and just as in
any field you have a genuine scientific
controversy about how fast or slow
things are gonna be but I think it would
be a mistake to dismiss it being passed
in part that it's possible you know sure
we have many embarrassing examples of
scientists being over optimistic of how
quickly things are gonna happen remember
when you and I were both starting grad
school Fusion was 40 years away oh yeah
it's still 40 years away the other hand
we thought we'd never know the density
of the universe yeah and now you know
one point see it's Times point seven
squared times anthem is 26 kilograms per
square meter and we've gone to about the
age of our universe from arguing whether
it's 10 or 20 billion years to arguing
about whether it's 13.7 or 13.8 so
that's progress and and so it's very
dangerous to say something is impossible
when you're on a planet with a lot of
smart motivated people for example
Ernest Rutherford right one of your
physics heroes for grandfather of
nuclear physics famously said that this
idea of getting nuclear energy moonshine
do you know how long it took from when
he said that in a lecture in London
until Leo Szilard invented the neutron
chain reaction it couldn't have been
that long a decade less than 24 hours
have to have an open mind yes should
happen in decades could be a bit sooner
it could be much take much longer but I
think if it's a few decades away that
already makes it arguably even more
urgent than thinking about climate
change and your retirement because this
is gonna be a much bigger deal obviously
if it happens if
if some human you don't like very much
think about your least favorite
politician or unscrupulous business
tycoon has this and can use it to take
control over earth and impose what they
think is cool on you you know might not
be so stoked about that right
alternatively so sorry just a I don't
want that to go by too quickly for the
people out there I mean this is the
worry of artificial general intelligence
that it will give either the AI itself
or the people controlling that AI some
version of superpowers that will be hard
to control for the rest of us and
therefore we should worry a lot about AI
gone wrong that's right and I think the
reason I decided to start my a iBook
like if you point out with a little
fiction story was exactly cuz of this I
Hollywood gets its worried always about
the wrong things it's always robots
because they have to have something they
can film because visual medium
intelligence itself can confer a great
power why is it that humans have more
power on this planet than Tigers is it
because we have sharper claws or bigger
biceps no it's because we're smarter
right and that means of course that if
someone can amplify their intelligence
with its vastly stronger AI it can
confer enormous power on them they can
pretty quickly outsmart others on the
stock market and how to patent them and
I would argue them on your blog and
whatever and and have a lot of influence
and is that good or bad well that
entirely depends on how its controlled
and with what goals I think um like any
technology of course AI will be a
double-edged sword people sometimes ask
me if I'm against AI here for it
I usually counter by asking them if
they're about fire like why they guess
that are for it like Donna it's the dumb
question the interesting question is
what can you do to get the upside of
fire but not the downside turns out
there's a lot to it that's why we have
fire extinguishers and fire escapes and
we teach our kids did not involve
hablaba you know that to me isn't is the
most interesting question important
question of our time I think how are we
gonna harness
just technology to make sure it gets
used to cure cancer and lift people out
of poverty and help life flourish like
never before hopefully not just during
the next election cycle but for billions
of years and maybe not just on this
planet but throughout much of our
universe right it could be awesome on
the other hand you don't have to think
too long to envision scenarios where
it's not so great for starters if you
just envision your least favorite
politician using it to impose their will
on everybody you don't even have to get
the things where they itself sort of
breaks out and takes over just a lot of
people you probably wouldn't want to
control you so I had the following word
you which I haven't really put in front
of AI experts such as yourself yet
if it's going to be AI at all it is
going to need the ability to learn and
therefore to change itself so is isn't
there an intrinsic issue with the idea
of controlling it like you can tell it
not to do something but if it decides to
change its mind what are we gonna do
about it this is a very active research
in AI today how to actually take these
deep learning systems which have learned
stuff and where you don't really
understand and detail how they work and
seeing it is there some way nonetheless
by having better architectures you can
actually prove that they're always gonna
do certain things or it breaks into
three different nerd problems which are
all unsolved but which we all also face
as parents I would say we want to a I
first to understand our goals and then
adopt our goals and then retain them you
know our little baby's first you're too
dumb to understand most of our goals and
then they're teenagers and don't want to
adopt our goals but fortunately our kids
spend several years this in-between
period where they're smart enough to
understand our goals and hopefully
malleable enough that we we have a
little chance at pretty enough that we
can control them yeah yeah and that's
what education child that's what
parenting is fundamentally about but
even if we succeed in getting AI to
understand our goals and adopt them how
can we make sure if they keep getting
smarter that they
between them you know like Philip and
Alexander you can see them those
pictures there when they were still
small enough that they thought Lego was
the coolest thing that was a big
priority for them now all those Legos
are gathering dust in the basement
tracer 18 and 20 if we create powerful
AI that has this goal to really take
care and protect humanity we don't want
it to become as bored with that this is
they got with Legos right yeah so you
would also like to have some sort of
recursive algorithm where you're
guaranteed that there are certain goals
it's always gonna retain and the
interesting news here is that there's
been a lot of technical progress
actually the we put a big effort in five
years ago with this future life
Institute to bring together AI
researchers and others at conferences to
talk about these technical questions and
with with a goal of mainstreaming that
research the more about would happen and
it's been very exciting to see actually
how much is taking place Stuart Russell
for example famous AI professor he just
has a new book out called human
compatible where he actually doesn't
just once again lay out these challenges
but actually proposes what he considers
a cool solution and um the good news is
we have we still have time maybe we have
you know a few days a few decades to get
this right my message is on one hand you
don't don't freak out and panic but on
the other hand work hard on these
technical questions now so we have so we
can get the solutions when we need them
because it might take that case right
rather than start working on them the
night before somebody switches on an AGI
well okay we're we're we're running low
on time but I do want to give this leads
very well in to you giving a little
sales pitch for the work that you're
doing now that I heard you talk about at
the most recent foundational questions
Institute where you're training a is to
be theoretical physicists right to find
the laws of nature by looking at big
datasets not just fine patterns but
really find quantitative laws what tell
us what that project is and how it's
going so we call it my grad students and
I the intelligible and
project so as you know most of the
progress in AI these days has moved away
from this old paradigm where a human
programs in the intelligence to a new
paradigm where the computer just learns
it itself usually better yeah at the
cost of you having no clue content or
nothing works he just knows better than
you it and that's fine if the stakes are
very small but if this is the thing
flying your airplane or your Boeing 737
max or controlling the nuclear arsenal
or something you'd like to have a higher
bar on really trusting the thing than
just some dude telling you that I
trained this on 15 terabytes of data and
it worked every time
and I'm quite convinced actually but we
can't make a lot of progress I think
there's a common misconception almost
like people almost worship the
mysteriousness of neural nets and say
part of the magic of them what that
makes them so powerful is that they're
inscrutable I think that's that's not
true I think the power of them doesn't
come from their instability but from
their while differentiability and nerd
speak but in plain English from the fact
that they're basically a black box with
a lot of knobs that you can continually
turn tune until they work really really
great so they can learn for themselves
from data and what I would really like
to see is where we combine the best
aspect of this new paradigm of machine
learning we're the old school thing with
with little programs are you the human
understandable and simple we humans
actually know it's possible because we
do it in our brains right if someone
teaches you to play baseball whatever
you get pretty good at Abbott rating you
know or network but then if someone asks
you how does a ball move exactly you can
explain in English you can say that it
moves in this shape called the parabola
here's the equation for it yeah and
there is if we can do it and if you
don't think that intelligence is
something mysterious limited to by
organisms
is no reason we couldn't also develop AI
tools that can do the same you can first
use this power of deep learning to
figure out how to do stuff in an obscure
unintelligible way and then rather than
to stop at that point do some additional
things try to simplify down to something
that can be explained and understood as
you mentioned we've had some progress
doing this with simple physics problems
and if we could make more progress I
think there's a real hope here that we
can get systems that we trust better
trust for the really simple reason that
we actually can understand how they're
working you know the real threat from AI
systems today is not that they're gonna
turn evil like in some lousy Hollywood
movie but that we that they just turn
very competent and accomplish things we
didn't want them to accomplish because
he hadn't fully understood them Boeing
put this very simple system into their
737 max things and they hadn't
understood how it worked it didn't work
so well for them Knight Capital had this
trading algorithm that they hadn't fully
understood and it lost them ten million
dollars a minute kept going through 44
minutes until so we're look so we're
putting a I in charge of evermore
decisions and infrastructure just
affects people's lives and I think we
should and can raise the bar and making
sure that these are things we can
actually understand and since we're
running out of time to I say something a
little bit optimistic please this you've
been I liked it when an optimist decides
the risks get so much airtime because of
Hollywood movies and so on and yes there
are very serious risks I mean he founded
something called the future of life
Institute it begs the question of
whether or not life is something that we
might not have a future for well of
course if we create something is more
intelligent than us you don't have to
think very long about it until you
realize it yeah someone we don't like
could use it to do all of the bad things
of course things could go to hell in a
handbasket but that's just the nature of
powerful any powerful technology right
the interesting question
for me is not quibble about whether you
should worry or not the interesting
question is what can we do right now to
make to maximize the chances this goes
well first of all what we have to do is
some nerdy work like you discussed for
example try to build systems that we can
trust because we can actually understand
them better second we have to really
have a conversation about what kind of
future we actually want we're here in my
office at MIT right at this very table I
often have students coming in for career
advice I always start by asking them
where do you want to be in the future
and if she looks at me and all she can
say is oh maybe I'll get murdered
maybe I'll get cancer terrible strategy
for career planning right I want her to
come and I shining and saying max this
is where I want to be and then we can
talk about strategies for actually
getting there and all the pitfalls that
you should avoid right and that's what
we should do is a species also but our
we know we're doing exactly the opposite
we're doing precisely this sort of silly
thing that's that's fortunately I hope
she won't do we go to the movies and
watch sci-fi about the future and it's
almost always dystopian right which
makes us paralyzed with fear basically
and we really need to have a serious
conversation about what kind of future
high-tech future are we have truly
excited about what we also want to not
get murdered along the way of course but
it has to start with a shared positive
vision that's so cool that you get
people in China and in Russia and in
Kansas and in LA all I'm bored about it
saying this is the future for Humanity
that we all were all with Olga we're all
going to be much better off we would
like this to happen that fosters
collaboration and that's the time to
start making a list of the things that
can go wrong that you have to then make
sure you avoid people if you can't start
by even giving the positive vision
they're not gonna want if you can feel
it's a waste of time talking about those
things right in 1945 people in Europe
you know where I was born looked at each
other and said oops
we screwed up again you know and
something really remarkable happened
some people decided see if they could
come up with a really positive vision
for a change for how they were gonna use
this ever improving tech for not just
making ever more powerful weapons but
maybe create a society that was awesome
where you everybody can have free
healthcare free college education free
pensions and it's society where
everybody was better off and I'm pretty
sure the back in those days they got a
lot of they got poo pooed a lot and uh
go smoke some weed huh guitry you know
it's never gonna work
but the positive vision was compelling
enough and realistic enough that they
got enough support that it started to
happen in countries like Sweden England
Germany and soon in and by now it's
happened in all rich industrial
countries except for when they were in
and that's the power of a positive
vision right and I would like to see a
new vision which is much more ambitious
that's powered by a eye for how we can
have a truly awesome future for
everybody on the planet where we amplify
our own intelligence with with
artificial intelligence to solve all the
problems that we're stumped on now and
we and we think hard about also how
we're gonna not just make the tech but
how are we gonna make sure that it's
deployed in to help everybody rather
than just to help me max who owns all
the text to take over and screw all the
rest of you if we can have such a shared
vision then I think it's really much
much more likely that we're gonna get it
all right I love it I love the
optimistic way to end I do want to
foresee the future where you and your
students build little AI agents which
get conscious enough that they can deny
that we exist refuse to believe they
live in a simulation I would I would
love to have that alright max tegmark
thanks so much for being on the podcast
thank you
[Music]